so
next round against shanti is god well
why hope that the bad game
that
god exchanged this fidor
story again that's amazing
how many do that
yes
i really don't know what's there there
exactly is running 106 x
10.7 or the 88
yes me  was
apparently believes can somehow
just cheer everything forward and
win then yes maybe it will be
fine if I now I take five then
h6 yes yes I not such a problem could
also play runner i7 just
on fw then springer ag four
springer f2
er  I have
to take care of it somehow
now if I can just take her 5 m knight
again, yes, I can
simply give Black an advantage
due to the better pawn structure
and also the potentially better bishop
because the holder is
on white to the pawns e4
so I just don't have to look there  just which
flower tricks it has developed a little better here has
springer the threesome could be stupid
I don't really want to swap  en
true maybe that's not so
easy to prevent
good that likes it
is still
the cementing again of
course also nice made
me an ID thank you
jumpers the three can
still do one more on white my god
my okay i understand that
maybe at some point about the g3 but that's
somehow still nothing to see how
that should work
well exchange something and then you're
really good so that if he
would take e5 that's no problem the
question is why does it work  you
now swap the knight with the back of c
who really isn't that bad but
i don't want to do it that much
maybe also jumper e6 with the idea
and jumper ag 5 he also gave
me a horse
there circumstances also jumper the 4
only disadvantage of  the whole action
is that he is now a g4 bishop,
unfortunately i noticed it too late,
mine still a good
position then for black but that's
natural  Lich
has a main disadvantage then really
traded away yes what can you say
he just doesn't make any
normal moves like jumper
where the 5
so you also blogged that here
now maybe because the fw lines
are
now swapping that's the tone there totally
out of place  g4 and needs
a few moves again said game is does
it still maybe still
make sense that's not like that he can do that
on the second
he does he still have the problem that
this whole structure is totally passive so
the announcer always only covers during  i
attack
do another after eight years
yes i don't know where he wants to go
so exchange makes here i think
are even if he says funny on p4
just concrete if he now exchanges
toni four hang t4 and i'm still threatening tom
h 45
i have all of them  burglary fields
covered here that can't be found anywhere in the Rhine
so I'll just think about
what actually happens if I take the farmer with
us  nn I the pawn wars it is of
course
strong I have a direct good passed
pawn
thom f2 but the problem could be
too much I don't win
directly what I do and keep
the structure upright that should also be
good I mean I get it  yes with thom
h4 or record
i would actually have to get
the three pawns but i can also
give
on the the individual f3
ok
try to get over the sea each
pawn
still has no opponent
so he
can't go anywhere the horse
the three back at some point
we can of course bring the jumper
to zeven where he then also
grabs the pawns if
ok i put was already plattner
but first of all
right hit made another weakness
but it was probably
so broken
and  thankfully he was also
slower than I
attack three now again
prevent the jumper the 3
now it is  also gone
yes ok now you can also swap endgames as a pawn
it's just a bit of a run
yes it was a good position very early on
yes well i think yes
mf5 probably don't
do it at all i assume
so that that that  it's
excellent here it's a
bit of a game on a goal he has
weaknesses on weaker how much
he has systematically put things in somehow
an a4 e.g.
you don't need to play then on the
port and that's still on the internet
lost